Everyone knows about the Holocaust, the
Armenian genocide or
the Rwandan genocide.
But there's one genocide that achieved a
97% extermination rate
higher than any of these,
and most people have never heard of it.
Between 1880 and 1930, a
publicly traded company
systematically eliminated an entire
indigenous people in South
America. They paid bounties for
each person killed. They required
physical proof of death. They
specifically targeted women and
children to prevent reproduction. The
Selknam people went from over 3,000
individuals to fewer
than 100 survivors in 50 years. This is
the Selknam genocide
and why it matters now.
Picture the southern tip of South
America, Tierra del Fuego, land of fire.
For over 10,000 years,
this was home to the Selknam people,
master hunters who had
adapted to one of Earth's most
challenging environments. This wasn't
just survival, this was
sophisticated civilization.
The Selknam had complex territorial
systems, spiritual
ceremonies that lasted weeks,
and hunting techniques so advanced they
could take down guanaco,
South American llamas in arctic
conditions. According to
anthropologist Anne Chapman,
who interviewed the last survivors in the
1960s, they lived in
organized family groups with
populations around 3,500 to 4,000 people
when Europeans first
arrived. Until the 1870s,
their main contact with Europeans was
actually rescuing shipwreck survivors.
Chapman's interviews revealed that the
Selknam often saved and
protected stranded Europeans.
But around 1880, everything changed.
European businessmen
discovered that Tierra del Fuego's
grasslands were perfect for sheep farming.
There was just one
problem, indigenous people were
already living there. Here's where this
gets disturbing. This
wasn't random frontier violence,
this was systematic extermination
designed by corporate
executives with government backing.
The mastermind wasJosé Menéndez, a
Spanish businessman who
developed massive sheep operations.
According to survivor testimony recorded
by Chapman, Menendez
got permission from the
government to kill them. Menendez
employed Alexander
MacLennan, nicknamed Chancho Colorado,
or Red Pig as his administrator and
primary executioner.
Here's how the system worked.
Step 1. Hunters were paid one pound
sterling for each head.
That's about $150 today.
Step 2. They had to bring physical proof.
Ears, body parts to receive payment.
Step 3. They paid extra for killing
women. Federico, a
survivor interviewed by Chapman,
explained "For women they cut off the
breasts, then they paid a
little more for women. This
wasn't about protecting livestock, this
was about preventing
reproduction to ensure complete
elimination." In 1886, Romanian engineer
Julius Popper actually
photographed himself standing
over indigenous bodies he'd just killed.
This was documentation for
investors, proof that the
Indian problem was being solved. This
wasn't aberrant behavior.
This was a business model
that historian David Stannard calls
"extraction-based
genocide", systematic elimination of
indigenous peoples to access land and
resources for maximum
profit. Let me tell you about Lola
Kiepja. Born around 1874, she lived
through this genocide and
became the last traditional
Selknam shaman. Chapman worked with Kipya
until her death in 1966,
recording 47 traditional chants,
the last direct link to 10,000 years of
culture. Kipya
remembered specific massacres,
naming the killers, describing the
systematic nature of the
extermination. Chapman calculated
the demographic collapse precisely. 3,500
people in 1880, fewer than
100 by 1930, that's a 97%
extermination rate, higher than the
Jewish Holocaust, higher
than Rwanda. Kipya described
a massacre at Cabo Peñas, where McLennan
positioned armed guards with
Winchester rifles during high
tide. Families gathering shellfish were
trapped against cliffs as
the tide rose. According to
survivor testimony, women and children
were crowded where the
cliff was, and there they
drowned them all. Only one person
survived by hiding in the rocks. These
weren't combat deaths,
they were systematic executions of entire
families. They were witnessing a
prototype. The Selknam
genocide wasn't unique, it was a
template. The same pattern
appears across Latin America
whenever indigenous people live on land
with valuable resources.
Amazon rubber boom, 40,000
indigenous people killed by British
companies for rubber profits.
California gold rush, 95% of
indigenous people exterminated through
state-sponsored bounty
hunting. Guatemala in the 1980s,
200,000 people killed with 83% of the
victims being indigenous.
Corporate genocide requires
government support. Companies like
Menendez obtained official
permission to remove indigenous
populations. When survivors tried to seek
justice, Judge Waldo Seguel
deliberately protected the
perpetrators by falsely claiming
inability to find translators. This
pattern continues today.
70 indigenous peoples in Brazil currently
face extinction. Between 2012 and 2020,
363 indigenous activists were murdered
across Latin America.
Indigenous people comprise one
third of murdered environmental defenders
globally. Mining
companies, agribusinesses,
extractive industries continue targeting
indigenous territories
using legal frameworks,
hired violence and government complicity.
Until 2020, 90 years later, Chile
officially considered
the Selknam extinct. If they don't exist,
there's no crime to
acknowledge. But here's what the
corporate executioners didn't count on.
Survival and resistance.
Current census data records over
1,000 self-identified Selknam in Chile
and thousands more in Argentina.
Descendant communities like
Corporación Selknam are fighting for
territorial rights,
cultural recognition and justice.
Indigenous communities worldwide are
fighting the same extractive violence
that Chapman documented.
They are not just victims, they're the
primary opposition to systems that
prioritize corporate
profit over human survival. And this
matters to everyone because the same
systems that eliminated
the Selknam are driving climate change,
environmental
destruction and resource wars
that affect all of us. And Chapman spent
decades documenting the
Selknam genocide because she
understood that memory is resistance. Her
work proves that
systematic extermination operates
through formal business structures with
government sanction. Therefore,
recognizing these patterns
helps us understand contemporary
conflicts. Therefore, supporting
Indigenous resistance
helps disrupt these systems. Therefore,
this isn't just history,
it's a blueprint for action.
I've linked organizations in the
description supporting Indigenous
communities fighting these
systems. These aren't charities, they're
resistance movements
that need strategic support.
What surprised you most about this
documented genocide? How do
you see these patterns operating
today? Drop a comment below because
recognizing these systems is the first
step in disrupting them.
The Selknam deserved better. Indigenous
people today deserve
better. Chapman's research gives
us the evidence to understand how
genocide works and the responsibility to
stop it from continuing.